The Joe Rogan experience. There's two deathbed stories that I heard. All right.
One of them was, uh,
should I tell the sad one or the cool one first? It's up to you.
Okay. I'll tell the cool one first. Okay. We'll land in a dark place. Um,
so I remember here in Lou Reed, when Lou Reed was on his deathbed,
he was just sitting there relaxed, smiling with this look of like wonderment,
like enjoying this exp like your last experience,
I'm going to experience death. And he was open to it and,
and had like a little smile on his face. And it's just like, okay,
that's how I would like to go out and not being like, oh. Oh.
And then there was another one. I almost don't even want to say the name.
I'm not even gonna, it was this famous guy. And he,
he was a child star and I don't think he ever got past that. You know,
the ups and downs I was here and now I'm only here,
but he's still like doing these huge shows, but he's not as big as he was.
And his, his final words were so much wasted time.
And if you look at his career, it wasn't, he worked his off.
But then I'm th that's what scares the out of me. I'm like so much wasted time.
Did you played theaters for 40 years selling out and made millions of dollars
and you came out the other side with the w that was saying so much wasted time.
So that's kind of making me look at like, uh, you know, it's, it's,
there's this weird sort of thing with what we do. Like, oh,
this is exciting and stuff, but you know, you kind of also sit back like,
all right, well, I'm doing, if I,
if I do that too much and something else suffers,
or did I take the time, like, uh, you know, I have a pool I'm gonna,
I'm never in.
So it's just, just expensive puddle. Like, what am I doing with this thing?
And it's comes over to maintain your bottle, do it. And that was the dream.
I remember.
Living in play New York, no air conditioners,
like someday I'm going to get a house and I'm going to have a pool.
And on a day, like this, I'm going to jump into that thing. And, uh, yeah.
And on hot days like that, I'm not, I'm sitting in my office, you know,
working with this, something to be said about that.
Cause that's what you're supposed to do as a dad and everything. But then, um,
you know, there's also that other thing is like, if you work too much,
you end up being that guy laying there.
You probably will. Yeah. You know the thing about those guys? Well,
if you work too much, I'm saying, I think those guys that, uh, that so,
so much wasted time guys, you know, they're, they also,
it's very difficult when you're in a competitive business,
like show business to pay attention to just yourself and just like,
enjoy your experience and be in the moment everybody is looking at themselves
through the eyes of the success of other people.
Like I remember when I was on a news radio, um,
th the staff, everybody, uh, the crew, uh, the, uh, the, the cast,
rather everybody else besides me had a background show business.
All I had to do, I only had a background in stand-up.
I never taken acting classes other than a few private classes.
They made me take when they gave me a development deal.
So I didn't understand the culture of acting.
And I remember I was on the set and they would read variety,
or they would read the, you know, whatever those show Hollywood reporter.
And they would read about people getting deals.
And they would read about how well friends was doing and how well this is doing.
And they get so mad. And I, and I would, I would go, why are you reading that?
Like, you're reading the devil's rag. I go, you guys are upset. I go,
last time I checked, I'm on TV.
I'm a 27 year old kid and online TV, because that.
Was such a well-written well-respected show that didn't get
quite the shine that it should have. I felt, I felt,
cause that was a really, really,
really good show with like a ridiculous level talented cast and the social,
always those things.
But that's something you have to learn in this business that you just have to
accept that, like, you know, I always,
I quite a lot of things to like music that, you know,
you'll have like some pop star, you know,
some young guy or girl's going to come out prime of their life.
Good-looking singing some, you know,
bubblegum is always going to sell more than this other thing.
And you just have to, you gotta be okay with that. Yeah.
Because if you want to sell that, yeah, you gotta,
you gotta go do that bubblegum. And if you don't want to do that,
don't sit there and look at it and be upset.
The comparison is the thief of joy. It's a famous quote,
but it's an awesome one. It really is. It's you can set for a while. Yeah.
A lot of.
People do, especially show business.
Show business. That's a common thing amongst comics. It's a, you would see it,
this, this gleam of jealousy,
but I think also a part of there's good aspects of jealousy and that you
can feel bad that you're not getting something that other people are getting,
and then it makes you work harder. But then once you've achieved,
like a level of success where it's measurable, like where you like, Hey, look,
you're paying your bills. You're going,
you're doing shows and people coming to see you, like you're doing great.
Just concentrate on the work. Then concentrate on the work.
Don't concentrate on being at your best.
Don't concentrate on how well this guy is doing. And how will that?
I remember when Dan cook was killing it, there was so many haters.
And not just because of all the real reasons to be a hater,
but also just because of his success was so astronomical.
I remember people would just fume thinking about Dane, cook, selling out arenas.
It would drive them crazy. And I remember thinking like,
just concentrate on getting better catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan
experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Gerry on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan.